Longview
La question La préparation
donc la question la plus brûlante en ce moment
est une question qui est avec nous depuis
quelques décennies et qui serait les
problèmes causés par le changement climatique
mais nos questions les plus immédiates ont à
voir avec la crise du coven
avec la déstabilisation que cela
causé dans les sociétés
avec la montée des
totalitarismes ou ces inclinations
dans certains pays
et
avec
la conséquence
um recul des droits en
particulier des droits des femmes et
bien sûr au premier plan immédiat qu'ils
portaient en Ukraine
oui étranger et comme pour une personne de mon âge
donc je suis né en novembre 1939, ce qui
signifie deux mois après l'
entrée du Canada dans la Seconde Guerre mondiale
et le fait d'être dans une guerre, c'est
que vous ne savez pas comment ça va se
passer,
donc ça crée beaucoup d'anxiété J'ai
grandi  connaissant des gens qui s'étaient
échappés, cela a eu une très grande influence sur moi,
vous ne pouvez pas parler du 20e
siècle et laisser de côté la Première Guerre mondiale
et la Seconde Guerre mondiale, ils étaient  e ils étaient
des événements façonnant le monde et vous voyez
un autre événement de ce type en Europe en
ce moment
[Musique]
lorsque je l'ai écrit pour la première fois, c'était pendant une
période de complaisance aux États-
Unis qui avaient l'habitude de dire
bien nous '  re la plus grande démocratie du monde, de
telles choses ne peuvent pas arriver ici,
mais je n'ai jamais cru que
cela ne pouvait pas arriver ici, c'est donc au
début des années 1980 que j'ai commencé à
penser à ce roman juste après l'
élection de Ronald Reagan  et avait
commencé à démanteler le New Deal
qui avait fourni un filet de sécurité sociale
depuis l'époque des années 30 quand il a été
créé de sorte que reculait la
droite religieuse fondamentaliste
devenait une force politique
et je crois que les gens feront ce
qu'ils disent qu'ils '  Je vais faire
s'ils ont le pouvoir de le faire,
alors ma question était de savoir si le but est
de renvoyer les femmes à la maison,
comment allez-vous les y amener, comment allez-vous y
arriver maintenant qu'elles ont toutes un
emploi et et  cartes de crédit,
donc c'était une question, l'autre
question était si les États-Unis
devenaient une dictature totalitaire,
quelle forme cela prendrait-
il ne prendrait-il pas la forme du communisme,
il n'y aurait pas assez de partisans pour
cela, mais ils avaient suffisamment de fondements
pour le  la théocratie
parce que la Nouvelle-Angleterre a commencé comme une théocratie
donc les fondations sont là elles ne sont jamais
vraiment parties vous les filles servirez
les dirigeants
oui à l'époque les
gens ont dit soit hahaha ça
n'arrivera jamais ou aux États-Unis
ils ont dit eh bien ça n'arrivera jamais
nous '  re une démocratie libérale, nous ne ferons jamais
cela d'une part, mais d'autres personnes
là-bas ont dit
combien de temps avons-nous
donc les gens anticipaient déjà que les
choses pourraient se passer ainsi
dans les années
1980, c'était prévisible, les gens qui le regardaient
pensaient qu'ils allaient essayer  cela
a eu un effet inattendu
car tant qu'il était en place, les
gens pouvaient dire oh les choses ne vont pas si mal
quand vous enlevez cela
et aussi quand les gens se sentent t
Que leurs droits soient sérieusement
menacés
et que l'État en revendique la
propriété, cela les motive à voter et à
lutter contre la situation d'une
manière qu'ils n'auraient pas fait auparavant
dans la deuxième vague féminisme
que le mouvement était beaucoup plus fort au
Québec  que dans le reste du Canada
parce que cette génération de femmes au
Québec savait à quoi elles résistaient
dans leur enfance, elles avaient vécu sous
une politique très contrôlée, donc elles savaient
ce qu'elles voulaient renverser
alors que les gens du Canada anglais étaient
un peu plus
blasés à ce sujet
c'est
vrai, donc d'abord vous avez eu la Révolution tranquille
, puis vous avez eu le féminisme de la deuxième vague
et ces deux-là sont liés et ils
étaient tous les deux des réactions contre euh
euh le partenariat entre la duplicité
et l'église
c'est vrai
oui parce que parce que l'État
revendique la propriété de votre  corps
et euh c'est encore pire parce
qu'ils ne paient même pas pour ça d'
accord, donc si vous allez
enrôler des hommes pour être dans le a  rmy,
par exemple, c'est l'État qui revendique la
propriété de votre corps en vous disant quoi
en faire oh vous devriez avoir votre
nourriture vous logez vos vêtements votre
équipement et vos factures médicales sont
payées est-ce que quelqu'un propose de payer cela pour les
femmes qui sont forcées  avoir des
enfants contre leur gré si
vous obligez les femmes à avoir des enfants
vous devriez payer pour cela
vous ne pensez pas que
[Applaudissements]
est
unique
merci
oui parce que les choses se font toujours dans une
certaine mesure mais nous avons l'avantage
de ne pas  avoir juste deux partis politiques
donc ce n'est pas qu'il y a un
match de football constant que vous avez aux États-Unis
mon équipe contre votre équipe parce que nous
avons environ cinq équipes
est
[Musique]
pendant les moments de panique morale comme
la Révolution culturelle chinoise par
exemple et  Staline montre que les procès pour être
accusé, c'est être coupable,
donc les preuves n'ont pas d'importance à ces
moments-là
et et les premiers stades de moi aussi étaient
un tel temps,
alors devriez-vous accuser quelqu'un
sans preuves un  Et cette accusation devrait-elle
être l'équivalent d'un
verdict de culpabilité donc je suis je suis en faveur des preuves
et des faits prouvables ou réfutables
euh disons les points positifs que le
moment metoo euh a accompli euh à cause
de cela des institutions ont été mises en place
permettant de  signaler en toute sécurité des
accusations d'enquête
[Musique]
ce que je critique, c'est qu'une
accusation est l'équivalent d'une
condamnation
Je pense que le résultat a été plus
positif que négatif car il a
permis la création d'une infrastructure
qui a rendu les choses euh possibles
et plus faciles  et plus sûr
de dire réellement ce qui s'est passé
expressions
[Musique]
beaucoup
euh donc particulièrement quand il y a des
mouvements autoritaires à la hausse,
vous verrez une augmentation des
bannissements de livres euh je ne pense pas que nous ayons encore tout
à fait brûlé des livres mais  c'est
probablement la prochaine
euh alors ils s'en prennent aux artistes
parce que personne n'a une armée d'artistes
et ils ne sont pas un bloc de vote, ce sont des
individus, ils sont assez faciles à attaquer  ack
très peu de conséquences d'artistes écrivains
en tous genres vous avez vu qu'au Québec
pendant la guerre des mesures agissent que le
mouvement de censure peut se produire soit
à gauche soit à
droite alors en ce moment aux États-Unis c'est
la droite qui se trouve aller après
certains  des livres, mais il n'est pas
exclu qu'ils puissent faire
la même chose, donc les extrémismes des deux
types aiment censurer les livres,
que devriez-vous faire pour soutenir votre bibliothèque locale à l'
étranger, cela
dépend de quel pays je parle
, disons si je  parlaient à l'Iran, je
dirais qu'ils ne peuvent pas tous vous tuer,
mais disons aussi que ce sont les
jeunes femmes dont dépend l'avenir d'une
société,
c'est pourquoi tout le monde se bat pour elles
tout le temps
parce qu'elles sont si essentielles
vous êtes essentiel vous avez beaucoup de
pouvoir
vous l'utilisez pour de bon
ce qui est
exactement oui nous assistons à quelque chose
d'inédit et nous assistons également
à une révolution menée par des
jeunes femmes mais soutenue par  les hommes
et euh c'est que je ne pense pas que nous ayons jamais
vu ça auparavant,
donc c'est incroyable à regarder et j'entends
pas mal de gens là-bas parce que
bien sûr pour eux le conte de la servante
n'est pas une fiction
c'est ce qu'ils  dis-moi que nous avons
vécu
c'est
étranger